so growing up my favorite computer game
was sid maher civilization and this is a
game where you have to kind of take over
the world and build a civilization from
one city into global domination and what
i loved about it was there are multiple
ways to win you could win by destroying
every other civilization in the world
you could win by building a spaceship
and being the first thing at the space
you could have a cultural victory and be
the first to build the United Nations in
your civilization and there may be a few
other ways to win and most people I
think try to win by trying to destroy
all the other civilizations but that
wasn't me I rarely one that way maybe
that's some time for a good self
reflection on that as to why but you may
be thinking about what's relevant in
business you have to find the strategies
that work for you there's a lot of
different ways to win in business
there's a lot of different ways to win
with your company to achieve your goals
but not all of them are going to work
for you you've got to find the
strategies that work for your
personality so I was recently on a call
yesterday with a friend of mine who has
a consulting business and is trying to
take it off the ground how to get new
clients and we give them a whole bunch
of different strategies you know talking
about networking with other people and
forming alliances and going to
conferences and having a youtube channel
and have an e products and those are all
strategies that can work they all can
work but they all can't work for him and
I think a problem that a lot of
entrepreneurs faces they try to do
everything you see that something is
working for somebody so you try to apply
it to your business but you're fighting
to do it because it's not natural for
you it's not part of who you are and
where your business will take off is
when you feel like you're really
comfortable doing something because it
it feels right it's who you are and you
have a lot more success with it so give
you example my own case I hate
networking you know I'm not the guy who
sees somebody on an airplane who's
sitting next to me and strike up a
conversation and given my business card
I'm not that guy I'm generally pretty
introverted you may not believe it by
watching these videos but in general i'm
not the life of a party I'm not the guy
talking everybody I prefer to kind of
stay to myself and
could hurt me in business right if my
business depended on me being a great
networker then my business would fail I
wouldn't be an entrepreneur I'd be stuck
in some corporate job that I probably
hate and so I've managed to work around
that and while networking can work for
other people I find things that work for
me so my preference my strength is on
building up a lot of noise and building
up a community right so I kick up a lot
of dust in the entrepreneur community I
make these videos I'm active on Twitter
and Facebook I have a great newsletter
and that's what brings a lot of people
to me and it gets me speaking at those
events so instead of going to an event
and being a networker I'm off speaking
and then people come up to me afterwards
and want to talk to me and so I found
another way to do it right and that's
what you need to do for your business to
people will give you tons of ideas and
strategies and every day I share the
different strategies on this channel
something they're going to work for you
some of them are it's not that those are
bad strategies they just work for other
people and other personality types and
so I really encourage you to give
everything a try but if you don't enjoy
it you're not finding you getting your
flow with it then then stop don't try to
force yourself to do things that you're
not good at because if you don't have an
interest in learning it and you hate
what you're doing you're never going to
build anything great you're never going
to have huge success and instead if you
find a few things that you are really
good at and you enjoy doing and you want
to learn more about it and you go all in
on it and you maximize those strengths
you have a lot more fun you'll have a
lot more success and you'll be a lot
happier belief thank you guys so much
for watching I'd love to know from you
what you've tried before that you've
seen work for other people but you just
can't get it working for you for
whatever reasons leave in the comments
below I'm curious to find out thank you
so much for watching continue to believe
and I'll see you soon